oui vous savez j'ai une majorité solide
un très large spectre heureuse et donc
aujourd'hui je suis très très heureuse
que les sénateurs de paris iv pour les
socialistes mais aussi les écologistes
de paris mais aussi pierre laurent parti
communiste qui fait partie de ma
majorité mais aussi bien sur mon adjoint
aux finances qui est également
aujourd'hui élu sénateur de en marche et
puis 1 1 sénateur nouveau aussi bernard
jomier qui fait aussi partie de ma
majorité municipale dont moi je suis
très heureuse parce que finalement il y
à quelque chose d'assez logique d'ancrer
dans cette démocratie parisienne qui est
là qui est présent qui est respectueux
des différences et c'est de bonne augure
pour le travail que l'on va pouvoir
faire avec le sénat de bonne augure pour
aussi la façon dont on travaille dans la
majorité que j'ai l'honneur de réunir et
finalement cette majorité quand elles se
rassemblent et bien elle donne confiance
aux citoyens fusse-t-il des grands
électeurs
est-ce que vous n'y avez pas des
craintes avant cette élection la gauche
partait divisé contrairement à 2011
oui c'est vrai et puis il ya deux mois
trois mois de cela certains
ne misez pas sur le fait qu'on puisse
dépasser les 2 sièges d'envoyer quatre
sièges pour le parti socialiste plus le
siège des écologistes des verts et bien
sûr de bernard jomier ou de julien
bargeton voilà on se retrouve à un
niveau qui est le niveau d'une gauche
élargi et compris avec des centristes
élargi tels que nous avons obtenu la
confiance des parisiens en 2014 mais
peut-être aussi dans la lignée de ce que
l'on avait vécu aux précédentes
sénatoriales donc je suis très très
heureuse qu'il y ait cette stabilité
mais en même temps cette capacité à
rassembler à réunir à accepter des
nuances des différences tout en restant
finalement déterminé à servir les
parisiens